hi i'm selena gomez in Corsicana Texas
I'm about to go through some of my old
Instagram photos so GQ I have no idea
what you're about to pull from my past
but let's take a look um this one turn
up is real I was actually getting ready
to perform with my best friend Taylor at
the Staples Center so I was feeling
really hype and I put the caption as
when you hear your song at the club
cause I've only heard my song play at
the club three times and I lost my [ __ ]
it was so fun
Gigi so Gigi and I didn't know that we
were gonna wear the same dress on New
Year's so that's basically what this
photo is we were all in Dubai for New
Year's but we got ready separately and
when we came together we saw each other
wearing basically the same dress okay
well um this is what a normal day after
a concert looks like for me I have
horrible knees when I dance I have two
ice bags on my knees and I'm eating a
burger not a shocker next one this was
in Dubai I got to hold a real Falcon now
I look calm in the photo I gotta be
honest I was terrified uh this is me and
Taylor who are kind of the biggest
losers ever which is why we're friends
we spent 30 minutes trying to take this
photo and just that's us oh this was in
Mexico I wanted to leave LA to record my
record because this was such a
transitional period for me I was
figuring out what I wanted to say I was
experiencing things the whole world was
watching my story I'm pretty sure I came
up with the title of the album towards
the middle of the trip when I was
reading some things about my life that's
kind of my my time to kind of get me
inspired to be honest it does get me
down when people say things about me but
at the same time it motivates me because
I have something to say I think people
are quick to think they know me
this was also in Mexico the caption was
meant for me to kind of express my
confidence as kind of feeling a little
bit of the body shaming thing when I
realized that curves are actually sexy
now I'm happy about it I wanted to do
again I wanted to do a really like
staged beautiful photo I ended up
laughing at myself I'm very interactive
with my fans
so a lot of the comments that I'll read
are very they're very invested in my
life as I am with them so they were
talking about pickles and my love for
pickles and I reassured them with a
bikini photo naturally that my love for
pickles still existed so that's my
caption this is when I got my tattoo
probably the one that means the most to
me I did a concert in Dubai and a 16
year old came up to me when I was going
through a rough time she said I just
wish that you would love yourself first
I feel like you put people before
yourself which I do a lot of my fans
have actually gotten this tattoo I love
the conversation I love telling that
story I love what it means so yeah Cara
okay so this is when we were in Monaco
and it was really fun because I'm
terrified of helicopters I could ride in
planes all the time a car insisted on
making all these insane gestures to make
me laugh so we were being ridiculous and
posing in front of a helicopter but only
we were in for maybe 30 minutes it was
fun it was an experience with one of my
best friends so this is outside in the
backyard of my house when I first
decorated it I no longer have this house
but it was my first home the first time
I got to be independent and have my own
space this was in Malibu I was on a hike
that's exactly what the photos me and my
natural habitat a robe
Pantene to be precise and Hot Cheetos I
love hot cheetos and pickles my trainer
doesn't like that but I don't like my
trainer when she doesn't like that
I guess this was originally my most
liked photo and I had no idea why
because we were stuck in traffic for
like over an hour and it is my favorite
sweater
very comfortable ah
this was my 23rd birthday I spent it
with four people that would be my best
friends all my girlfriends and that's
all I wanted this was perfect I just
wanted to be with the people that meant
the most to me I didn't make a wish I
don't believe in wishes just pretty to
put a candle on a cake so this was
before I was going out with my girls in
my house it was the time where everybody
was posting a photo and they said haters
got me like GQ got me like those kind of
things it's not even that great of an
outfit I'm in jeans and a tank top
oh what a cry this is me and my papa
he's constantly breaking things to fix
them and I love that about him I did not
learn anything I don't know how to fix a
car it was simply there for a photo and
to talk to my papa and ask him questions
oh man this was in the studio I don't
know I'm immature sometimes I love food
but it's around I like making people
laugh so I started a food fight
I've been in a total of four food fights
my whole life five including a photo
shoot I did Watts this was Golden Globes
anytime I go to any event basically no
no I go with my best friend or somebody
that I know because you're around all
these people oh so good to see you let's
do lunch but we never will like that
kind of thing it's hilarious and I
thought it was spot on this was in the
backyard of my house Hit Boy Casanova
haze a few of his guys came over we
barbecued in the backyard I would rather
be with my friends and family at home
cooking than going out to dinner in need
a fax I'm having fun guys I'm reflecting
my life now I'm like first off I need to
delete some of these ridiculously cuz
you change so much you changed so much
when you're looking at this stuff this
is my perfect perfect god son my only
godson my first godson
best friend and my cousin who is six
months older than me she will make sure
that's known had a gorgeous baby with J
Cosme and I love him and I spoil him and
he's sweet this is me and my best friend
Ashley cook we were driving to Santa
Barbara for fourth of July I loved
stopping at random places I love meeting
people we just stopped got corn talked
to people oh gosh I love nothing more
than people playing with my hair that
was us one day sure we were watching
friends eating they were doing my hair
epic epic photo this was for the bad
blood music video she called me one day
and said let's do a video with all of
our friends just having fun coming up
with a story and when we got there it's
exactly what you would think it would be
exactly we were with our best friends
talking a boys talking about life and
meanwhile everybody looking absolutely
fire everyone looked gorgeous no we
don't look like that when we're eating a
burger I'll tell you that cuz I would be
mad if Gigi actually looked like that
eating a burger she's too perfect
well thank you guys I realized I need to
clean up my Instagram a little bit my
blast from the past and those are some
really fun stories I hope you guys
enjoyed it thanks for following me and
be sure to pick up GQ I don't even
remember this photo is this you versus
me so your photo that's you ha ha ha
you're lucky was that photo I scrolled
on